good morning believe nation today's
message is seek out excellence over to
you Michael martes I think it helps if
you try and enter an environment where
you think you can learn a lot and
whether that's inside an organization
doesn't happen have to be a company it
can be a me some other organization or
around people that you particularly
admire that you can learn a lot from and
I think that just helps expand ones
horizons and also gives the the
individual a sense of what excellence is
really like if you pick the right
setting all the right set of individuals
and done right it's a transformative set
of experiences and massively expands
your horizons and the sense that you
have of all the wonderful array of
opportunities that lie in from it I love
that he brought up environment here
because until you change your
environment you're going to keep getting
the same thing that you've been getting
you're not really going to hit that next
Plateau until you change your
environment because your environment is
too comfortable right now because to get
the mindset that you need to be able to
play up here instead of playing here you
need to change the way you think and
that's painful change equals pain for a
lot of people and so unless you're
constantly surrounding yourself with
people who guide you towards that change
you're going to start and stop and start
and stop and start and stop and so I
love the point of hanging around people
who are trying to build things that are
excellent I think you can also
accomplish it through your routine
through the resources you consume I've
talked about this a lot on the channel
especially recently I think and do it
from the books that you read I think you
can do it from the videos you watch the
reason
I made the top 10 series in the end
special series was for me and for you
guys to be around super successful
entrepreneurs you may never meet but
hopefully a little bit of their magic
rubs off on you to start changing the
way that you think if you just watch one
video it may not spark enough of a
change but if you do it consistently
over time you'll see how much of your
attitudes when your belief in your
mindset have shifted one of the things
that I do with the leaders on my team
that I'm training and I want to build up
to be visionaries is I have them watch
the top 10 series every day so alex has
been on the channel who's with me here
at Toronto dance salsa hi my name is
alex when he's eating his lunch he's
watching the top 10 series because I
want him to learn from steve jobs and
Martha Stewart and Oprah Winfrey and
Walt Disney and Warren Buffett and even
though he's never going to meet Steve
Jobs or Walt Disney he's spending a
little bit of time with them or with
someone of their caliber every single
day and that shifts his mindset slowly
slowly slowly every single day he is
getting a little bit better he started
to think a little bit different you
certain surroundings up with excellence
and that turns him into the Alex that he
can be and I want the same thing for you
I want you to surround yourself with
resources ideas a force you to be more
excellent than who you are right now and
do a consistently because that
consistency will lead to change so the
question day today is how do you seek
out excellence leave it in the comments
below I'm going to join the discussion
thank you guys so much for watching have
an amazing day continue to believe and
i'll see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot event specimen
express the TV go